دخل الفن كجزء من عائله هوى اطفالها العمل
التلفزيوني ثم اصبح يتنقل بين بوابات
العمل التلفزيوني فتاره كان منتجا وتاره
كان موسيقيا لكن الجمهور اختاره ليكون احد
اهم فنان عصره لاسيما انه سقط اكثر من مره
قبل ان يقف على رجليه من جديد معلنا انه
ليس بطل الجوكر فقط بل جوكر فني بامتياز
انه النجم الكبير خواكين فينيكس فما قصته
ولكن اسرته انتقلت الى لوس انجلوس وهو في
سن صغيره حيث وجدت وكيلا كان على استعداد
لتبني مواهب اطفالها الخمسه فانخرط خواكين
مع اشقائه في العمل التلفزيوني وظهروا معا
في الاعلانات التجاريه للحوم والحليب
والوجبات السريعه اما اول ظهور حقيقي له
كان كضيف مع شقيقه
بالمسرحيه الهزليه
عام
بعد عامين شارك خواكين وشقيقه في فيلم
قبل ان يبدا عمله بمفرده فظهر لاول مره
على الشاشه الكبيره كاصغر عضو في طاقم
الفضاء بفيلم
كما حظي باول دور بطوله له في دراما عصر
الحرب البارده راسكيز في اواخر
الثمانينيات
حيث افتتحت يونيفرسال استوديو جديدا في
المنطقه فحصل اخواكين على دور البطوله في
فيلمكس شكل خواكين مع شقيقه ثنائيا فنيا
ناجحا وكان يتقدمان خطواتهما معا حتى
نهايه اكتوبر من العام
1993 حيث توفي
متاثرا بجرعه زائده من المخدرات كان
خواكين من ابلغ عن حاله شقيقه عندما كان
يحتفلان معا في ملهى ليلي وسقط على الارض
فقامت وسائل الاعلام باعاده تشغيل مكالمه
اخواكين برقم 911 وبثها اثناء نقل الخبر
ما فاقم حزنه الذي ابعده عن العمل لاكثر
من عامين في عام
1995 عاد خواكين الى الشاشه مع دور مراه
المنبوذ في فيلم تداي فور الذي تبعته
سلسله من الاعمال كان اهمها اداءه دور
الامبراطور الروماني في فيلم غلادياتور
حيث تم ترشيحه لجائزه اوسكار وجولدن كلوب
كافضل ممثل مساعد كما لعب دور المغني
الشهير جوني كاش في فيلم
الذي صدر عام 2005 قبل ان يعلن اعتزال
التمثيل في عام 2008 ليكرس نفسه للموسيقى
عمل خواكين بين المنتجين التنفيذيين
للبرنامج التلفزيوني ريل 4 وفي فيلم
كما قام باخراج مقاطع فيديو موسيقيه لفرق
عديده مثل رينجسايد وشيوان
رغم اعلانه الاعتزال استمر خواكين في
العمل كمنتج وممثل في بعض الا بشكل متقطع
وكان من ابرزها
الذي نال عنه جائزه افضل ممثل في مهرجان
كان ثم جاءت دور الاهم في فيلم جوكر الذي
ظهر في نسخته الاولى عام 2019 وحصل عنه
على جائزه الاوسكار لافضل ممثل الى جانب
الاوسكار تم ترشيح خواكين لاكثر من 120
جائزه فنيه فاز بسبع واربعين منها على
الاقل كان من اهمها جائزه جولدن جلوب
والبافتا وجوائز نقابه الفنانين وجائزه
الاكاديميه البريطانيه للافلام وجائزه
غرامي الموسيقيه كما جمع ثروه تقدر بنحو
75 مليار دولار
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]